leaks from the upcoming tell-all book
supposedly tell all from Jim Comey seem
kind of more tabloid than telling the
former FBI director reportedly reveals
such nuggets as president Trump's hands
are smaller than his Trump's ties are
too long and he looks like he's using
tanning goggles for good measure Comey
also reportedly calls Trump unethical
and a liar
Democrats mace won over the book just as
they cheered commis role in the Russia
investigation but many are still livid
let's face it over commis reopening of
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
late in the campaign believing it could
have cost her the election our next
guest former Clinton advisor Phillipe -
has some choice thoughts on Comey
also joining us former White House press
secretary Ari Fleischer gentlemen great
to see you now I'm sorry this book if
usually you put out your really hot
stuff either to get people to buy I go
to the bars unknowable if this is what
this is all they have of most of wadiya
I think it's a big snore I don't I do
not see why this book is even gonna sell
copies but let's start with the personal
stuff because it seems very petty Ari
well he called him a congenital flyer
actually in an unethical man and my
point here Laura is if that's what the
head of the FBI thought about the
commander-in-chief the president to whom
he does report even though he is a
ten-year term is independently appointed
the president runs the executive branch
the honorable thing would have been for
James Comey to resign that's what he
should have done how can he work for
somebody he considers unethical and he
does work for the president he is the
FBI director one of the most important
and powerful positions of government
that answers to the President and so the
honorable thing if that's what he
thought would be to resign he didn't do
that and James Comey I know has always
been a grandstander as Sylla
grandstander and this book just shows
that even more so there's an interesting
tweet today by former FBI agent James
gaglianone we're gonna read it James
Comey book section 2.4 of FBI's
pre-publication review manual covers
prohibited disclosures FBI employees
shall not
disclose information that relates to the
substantive merits of any ongoing or
open investigation or case just gonna
leave that right there you know the
implication being he shouldn't be
talking about shouldn't be talking about
this investigation or anything close to
it really well look I mean I have more
reason than you or I or anyone watching
to disparage Jim Comey he in no way
helped Hillary Clinton Donald Trump I
can make the argument wouldn't be in the
White House now without him and Hillary
Clinton did in part right yeah and I
believe that and I think Donald Trump
would be in Trump Tower or towering
inferno which I think I know but
liberals really celebrating the fact
that someone you know I fired in Trump
Tower I think it did but that's oh
that's all that's kind of a wild thing
no repercussions for those comments
nobody percussions for ya so moving on
Paul Begala this is interesting cuz you
probably agree with him he said mr.
Comey needs to put his big-boy pants on
admit that his unethical actions swung
the election to trump and begged for
forgiveness
basically on the book tour yeah my aunt
Fanny's bean dip makes me mildly
nauseous
call me swinging the election to Trump
makes me sick that's a good makalah line
I love that look I agree every time I
see him I throw up a little bit in my
mouth the idea that he is he's a
sanctimonious righteous self-involved
person but a word that I've not used
with him and I don't believe is I don't
think he's a liar if you don't like him
you don't like what the book says don't
buy the book he's trying to sell a book
but this is not what's happened we are
where we are this is about Bob mother
Bob Muller is in the middle of doing
something and we don't know what he's
doing but we know what the Republican
Party is doing we know what the
president is doing they're doing
everything they can to stop like this
man well like the Democrats tried to I
mean they're Democrats tried to you know
go after Ken Starr and the 90s there but
I don't think that's a good example
because ken starr started at 94 and
actually went on beyond Bill Clinton
being in office so I don't know why
what is everyone afraid of to just let
this man do his job there's a there's
another issue in us James commis
judgment which gets to the core of
whether he did a good job as the head of
the f
and take the investigation of hillary
whether you agree with what he found or
didn't James Comey had no role or
responsibility to usurp the duties of
the department the Attorney General at
Department of Justice and decide that no
reasonable prosecutor would settle this
case the proper thing to do would have
been to silently make his defined as
known to the Department of Justice and
let justice act but Comey couldn't do
that because he couldn't resist the
camera and so he had to go out and hold
a news conference where he concluded
basically and everything other than the
law that Hillary broke the law and then
he said but no reasonable prosecutor
would prosecute people re he allowed he
allowed Peter Street and others to edit
edit the remarks to to make this
judgment so I mean how do you do that I
want to wait that's true
we are where we are Comey but so what
just don't buy his bleep I want to read
this one thing this is a full screen
another excerpt from the book that came
out today it is entirely possible that
because I was making decisions in an
environment where Hillary Clinton was
sure to be the next president my concern
about making her an illegitimate
president by concealing the restarted
investigation bore greater weight than
it would have if the election appeared
closer or if Donald Trump were ahead in
all the polls but I don't know Jim Comey
tortured everything reporter prior to
election day and I really don't care
whether he says sorry
it's apology not accepted yeah call me
standard justice by polling re-home East
is my polling he is enjoying being the
hero and the victim and the spotlight
and the author and the guest we all have
to endure it for 15 minutes but he
started something that was based on
legitimacy that it's been handed over to
Bob Muller almost a legitimacy I'll tell
me we can do an hour on that whether it
was a legitimate opening of an
investigation 19 just decided you have
five people who are green - yeah we
could we could go through we go through
you know a floor of any building
we could if we die so much now there
being a problem can I read something
Muller was quote a person of high ideals
a clear sense of an obsessive devotion
got a Nobel Prize you know who said that
Republicans that doesn't mean it sorry
Oh Ari so you say mm I still believe
that Iowa dammit believe all right
you've talked enough I still believe
that about Bob Muller I've always said
about Bob Muller Bob Muller is not James
Comey but James Comey so it shows is
that prosecutors who have bad judgment
will make mistakes and not everybody is
perfect at the Department of Justice or
the FBI that's a interesting and
important reminder for Bob Muller as he
goes forward but when we know about
James Comey and you said affiliate is
that the things he did before the
election are wrong and that goes back to
the Bush administration to when he grant
standard on one of the intelligence
programs that we had and created this
whole drama about himself when there was
a program the FBI had previously
approved the Justice Department
previously approved and then James Comey
had this dramatic moment at a hospital
to reverse everything
the Department of Justice previously did
the man in a town of grand standards is
one of the big this is call me on
Loretta Lynch and whether she was
impartial the source and content of that
material remains classified as I write
this had it become public the unverified
material this isn't material he has on
Loretta Lynch would undoubtedly have
been used by political opponents to cast
serious doubt on the Attorney General's
independence in connection with the
Clinton investigation wait so we find
out in this book that there is
information that may call call into
question the Attorney General's
independence and overseas we already
investigation what no we don't we do he
left it out because he's embarrassed the
Washington Post reported months ago it's
not confirmed that he fell for a fake
email that someone of the Clinton
campaign central woman named Loretta
Lynch who is an energy lobbyist in
California I mean the guy is naive the
guy is a rube but again Bob Muller is
the man we should be talking about Bob
mother was appointed by God we're
talking about calm because he's writing
a book that's exactly
the investor usually here's the other
thing
call me is Madea fide by the press corps
the press corps loved him when he took
on bush they loved him when he let
Hillary go and now they love and I bet
you on his toward nobody's gonna ask
some hard questions because I'm back
such as you said that you'll eat that
memo to the Columbia University
professor who else did you routinely
leak things can you with but yeah that
we forgot to rent mention that right now
I'd love any of the car and write some
memo to the file is not someone I trust
sorry that's a cya type of I don't like
I'm not doing that one yeah hi